[Musik]
sebastian packt ganz dicke maschinen aus
für richtig billiges essen
damit nichts schief geht ist die
feuerwehr am start mit einer kanone
marke eigenbau lässt er es richtig
krachen
es gibt pulver snacks und tütensuppen in
xxl länge feuer frei
ab geht's jetzt knallt gleich richtig
das wichtigste utensil eine puff kanone
puffreis kennt jeder
oder die berühmten weißen pops zum
frühstück aber heutzutage wird wirklich
alles geputzt alles wird knusprig luftig
leicht hergestellt haben sie ja schon
mal gefragt wie das gemacht wird
wir haben eine selbst gebaute schiff
kann ohne alles was stärker haltig ist
ein bisschen wasser noch entfällt also
restfeuchtigkeit lässt sich super
aufrufen in der puff kanone werden wie
körner mit etwas wasser erhitzt der
druck des heißen dampfes presst die
getreidekörner in ihren weichen schalen
zusammen wird der dampf auf einen schlag
freigelassen lässt der angestaute druck
im korn die hülle platzen und die stärke
aufrufen
soweit die theorie
jetzt geht es an die praxis
[Musik]
ganz wichtig eine leder richtung weil es
darf ja vorher nicht ein bisschen druck
verloren gehen weil den druck wir
brauchen wir damit bei den schlagartigen
befreien doch alles auf platz
fürs perfekte puppen wird eindruck von
35 bar benötigt und eine temperatur von
bis zu 300 grad garantiert nichts was
man zu hause nachmachen sollte
[Musik]
frauen
aber fachmann lege weiß wie es geht
ja geil
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es hat funktioniert der sind die
geprüften reiskörner sauer
naja zwar nicht alle aber schon einige
sind hier auf geprüft wird so noch
selbst geworden kanone gar nicht
schlecht das ergebnis akzeptabel ich
freue mich dass puppen verzehnfacht sich
das volumen der reiskörner für die
industrie ein profitables verfahren aus
gerade mal 200 körnern lässt sich eine
ganze packung reiswaffeln herstellen mit
entsprechendem gewinn ein rechenbeispiel
ein kilo reis kostet knapp drei euro ein
kilo geprüft 17 euro die eine packung
körner füllt durchputzen nun zehn tüten
knusperhaus das entspricht einem
preisaufschlag von nahezu 500 prozent
[Musik]
amaranth und quinoa samen kannte man
lange nur in südamerika als sogenanntes
super food liegen sie inzwischen auch in
deutschland voll im trend
super vor allem für die industrie denn
ein drittel der kunden sind bereit für
die vitaminreichen körner tiefer in die
tasche zu greifen
und natürlich gibt es auch die super
körner längst geprüft
[Musik]
aber überstehen die vitaminreichen samen
die behandlung mit hitze und hochdruck
überhaupt immerhin verkaufen sich die
eher teuren produkte vor allem wegen
ihres gesunden images gut wir schicken
proben ins labor
de facto ist es so dass die das putzen
die hitze behandlung insbesondere die
damit verbunden ist
dazu führt dass vor allen dingen vitamin
b1 als das haupt vitaminen meisten
getreidesorten deutlich reduziert wird
in seinem gehalt das wichtige vitamin
geht zu 80 prozent verloren
die gesunde wohl säure allerdings bleibt
weitgehend erhalten
geprüfte körner sind also nicht wertlos
aber weniger gesund als ungeprüfte und
es gibt noch einen anderen haken
häufig sind diese geprüften produkte
allerdings entweder stark gesalzen im
sap bereich oder sehr stark gezuckert im
frühstücks cerealien bereich und dann
kommen andere aspekte rheinseiten es ist
aber nicht das gibt das buchen sollst du
so sehr sondern eher die begleitenden
zutaten nur in maßen gesund aber knusper
leicht und ein bombengeschäft für die
lebensmittelindustrie dem puff trick sei
dank
für den nächsten trick setzte bastian
ist ausdruck sondern auch hitze für eine
cremige spargelsuppe heizt er seine
trocken trommel
in seiner werkstatt nimmt sebastian die
tütensuppen genau unter die lupe
auf der verpackung appetitliche bilder
von frischem gemüse und kräutern
doch steckt das auch wirklich drin
[Musik]
es raschelt
ein blick auf die zutatenliste zeigt der
prozentsatz an gemüse und kräutern ist
oft verschwindend gering
[Musik]
die hauptzutat ist eine ganz andere
nicht nur pommes und kartoffelpüree den
jungs steckt nur kartoffelstärke
erstaunlich kartoffelstärke ist die
hauptzutat vieler tütensuppen die stärke
verwandelt heißes wasser in eine cremige
suppen und saucen basis
geschmacksneutral und günstig eine wahre
wunderwaffe der lebensmittel designer
sebastian lege demonstriert wie die
industriekartoffeln in feinstes stärke
pulver verwandelt
doch welche anstrengend
schritt nummer eins verreiben sieht aus
wie reibekuchen machen ist es aber nicht
denn hier geht es nur um den kartoffel
saft
und hier haben wir schon den ersten shop
von unserer wertvollen stärke
[Gelächter]
tatsächlich wirkt sich die stärke nach
einer weile vom restlichen saft ab für
die weitere verarbeitung aber noch nicht
ideal
die muss jetzt auch getrocknet werden um
bekommt man richtig feuer unterm hintern
für den folgenden schritt hat sich
sebastian professionelle aufpasser
geholt
so jungs fordert mal ein bisschen kochen
denn zum trocknen der stärke hantiert
der produktentwickler mit offenem feuer
ab geht's das schwere gerät ist eine
selbstgebaute trocken trommel
sie soll im handumdrehen die stärke von
überschüssigen wasser befreien
auch die industrie wendet dieses
verfahren an nur sind die trommeln dort
viel größer doch das prinzip ist das
gleiche
die kartoffelstärke wird dünn auf die
oberfläche der inneren trommel
aufgetragen
[Musik]
dann heizt sebastian die äußere trommel
auf
jetzt muss es richtig schon getrocknet
werden weil wir wollen ja schnee weißes
pulver erhalten ansonsten würde es
verbrennt die flammen dürfen deshalb
nicht direkt mit der stärke in berührung
kommen die hitze abstrahlung der äußeren
trommel genügt um den stärke 3 im
inneren zu trocknen und so die begehrte
zutat für fertig suppen und soßen zu
gewinnen
[Musik]
jetzt formiert
es löst sich richtig feines pulver von
meiner träume
sofort seien sogar ohne sie zu zermahlen
verfällt die kruste zu feinstem stärke
staub endlos lagerfähig und vielseitig
nutzbar
mit diesem pulver habe ich ihnen jede
suppe und soße diese wollen
[Musik]
dazu benutzt der produktentwickler ganz
wie die industrie aromen und farbstoffe
auch die gibt es fast alle in pulverform
kleinen suppen kopf her gefällig die
hauptzutat kartoffelstärke am ende soll
eine spargelcremesuppe entstehen deshalb
greift lege zum spargel aroma eine
kleine menge reicht für einen intensiven
geschmack
[Musik]
palmfett sorgt für einen sonnigen
schmelz auf der zunge getrockneter
schnittlauch suggeriert frische dann
natürlich getrocknetem spargel aber
nicht zu viel
das wird es uns viel zu teuer
die wenigen brettchen trocken spargel
quellen später auf das dient vor allem
der optik bewegungen fertiges die
tütensuppe
[Musik]
sobald die pulver mixtur mit wasser in
berührung kommt will die kartoffelstärke
darin auf es entsteht eine sämige
konsistenz
[Musik]
und sie sieht der traditionellen
spargelcremesuppe zum verwechseln
ähnlich
[Musik]
fertig ist unserer instant spargelsuppe
cocktail aus kartoffelstärke
[Musik]
schmeckt lecker nach spargelsuppe aber
in dieser suppe gerade mal so viel
spargel
[Musik]
wusstet ihr dass solche höllenmaschinen
für puffreis und tütensuppen nötig sind
sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in den nächsten
zwei clips
[Musik]